welcome to this video playing Scott Shaw
Scott Shaw and maybe that's the way to
pronounce it I am from Spain okay what
are you going to do now c4 Knight f3
Bishop g5 I just had him once before
with the win Wow 93 that's um that's
uncommon what is that is there a way to
exploit this um g5 Bishop g5 I can
easily easily transpose to a French
defense should g5 should be sentenced to
just thinking how to avoid transposing
to the French for sense idea probably
okay yeah white is well developed in
this position how do I play this I don't
want to castle really to give him a 5
there should be seven Bishop d3
let's ply plainer somewhat slow fashion
maybe try to provoke him to play five
somehow so that the center is closed and
they can decide about my Kings position
a little bit later again now he closes
them meaning the whole thing okay oh he
allows if if he easily a now c5 I'm
going to play that I mean okay I can
probably play it anyway but a very slow
move like 92 pretty much invites invites
this mm should be six or not don't know
maybe I could have done that this is
also not not bad interesting way to to
play here on the light squares Quint go
into a four maybe maybe I can really get
an early initiative going on the
queenside
I expect 93 overnight there for him
it seems seems unclear complicated
pollution they F both have the idea both
night moves to get in night h5 yeah well
I was a bit surprised that he took so
long for that move looked very very
logical in some way yeah nights if maybe
nights you for irritated him but he can
just throw to see to I don't have
anything great down Queen a4 is an
interesting way to play let's try that
it's probably a bit risky but
interesting night h5 okay okay that was
the idea anyway where is he going now
going Queen b3 next trying to win this
pawn
yeah maybe I can never take it and this
is all very naive possible but the way I
played it it's hard to how to do
anything else now might be - yes would
be one especially after castling and
Queen B - Bishop c4 it's not working at
all
I am so he still did still tries to
somehow cover it hmm we should see -
might be might be an issue
we should see two hundy five I don't
know oh yeah I should have played this
in a simpler way don't like my position
here it looks kind of shaky angling 492
I don't know
a four might be good here okay oh he
just wants to give give this cheque at
the end there oh wow no I did not I did
not understand the idea yeah I did not
understand this idea at all no no I
didn't I didn't didn't get that Queen a
for Bishop b5 check crenate so it's
totally ridiculous yeah I have to do
that oh wow how is he going to kill me
now Janice this looks awful King where
to da to evade I don't know what a funny
game how do I get can I can I somehow
get my queen out of that maybe c4 rook
takes Queen B to 1/2 C 2 and square oh
man what did I do
just great that said at the moment I
don't see how he wins it but it's kind
of not believable that there isn't the
win over the Queen then it is definitely
some way to win it okay so he tries the
that looks like a very brutal way and
maybe it works I cannot really not take
or that is of course a simple way to do
it this should be a six would would save
it would save the queen' time morning
but at the cost of two ponds Jam what a
disaster right what a disaster
that's the jinx of the autumn hire once
when you knew when you're close to it
you're kind of starting to to play
nonsense what a bad idea are just the
silly Queen maneuvers could have had a
perfectly normal position without it
there are many I can also just resign
yeah but yeah I feel I need to be
punished a little bit here
there's some some way here to look you
wanna look F - this is kind of a little
shock maybe okay follow that I know I
guess he saw that okay one here and it's
still not going going to work just
having this check on c6 I don't know
it's lost anyway check okay
Oh black resigns yeah I was a really
really getting between on the queenside
Oh way okay so I think I'm okay like up
to here but I should I should really
really really not put the Queen there
okay especially especially this a5 and
was kind of I mean it probably probably
still playable up up to here but now I
really have to do something there if
five is like like that's really a silly
idea that's just a very silly idea if I
now play a normal move I'm probably
still kind of in the game but it's of
course quite quite silly to play like
that maybe I should have just played
like Bishop a 16 or so and and I'm okay
that's definitely a good French
structure Knight to c6 just plain normal
moves yeah I played far too fancy with
this Knight a5 stuff here black is just
okay
96 and normal development something like
let's say I don't know this is this kind
of this kind of business g6
96 long castles or so this is like a
normal French wow what a game thanks for
watching